it's been 20 years since Seinfeld left
TV and its ratings grabbing final
episode remains divisive among both
critics and fans here's what happened
during the last episode of this
long-running sitcom and how it fits into
the rest of the hug free learning free
laugh filled show about nothing is a
character on the show
right and it's about nothing absolutely
breaking the mold while sitcoms existed
before Seinfeld no other show captured
the quirks of everyday life quite like
it
older sitcoms relied on likable
characters and goofy hijinks
but Seinfeld in contrast famously had
the unofficial motto of no hugging no
learning in one of many tongue-in-cheek
plots we even watched characters pitch a
Seinfeld
esque show to an NBC executive as a show
about nothing I think I can sum up the
show for you with one word the show's
tendency to make episodes out of
anything meant that viewers had no idea
what the show would focus on week to
week viewers could jump in anywhere
without getting lost and the characters
a Seinfeld would never learn a lesson
even if they really should that all
changed in the series finale looking up
the series finale starts off on a
positive note Jerry and George seemed to
have finalized their deal for the
Seinfeld esque show they're making
called Jerry he wants to sit down with
us and talk about Jerry a show Jerry
right Shari oh my god he wants to talk
about Joey
yeah network executives even loan the
cast of private jet so Jerry and his
pals decide to go to Paris it's about
the happiest ending the self-obsessed
crew could get so of course it doesn't
last almost immediately they muck things
up by nearly crashing the plane and get
stuck in a small Massachusetts town
while they wait for it to get fixed in
classic Seinfeld fashion they witness a
crime and crack jokes instead of helping
the victim
amb food however the characters aren't
in New York and their big-city attitude
lands them in court for failing to help
they finally experience real
consequences for their daily rudeness
almost as soon as they leave New York
Karma for past deeds of course it's
ridiculous that they were arrested for
failing to help a carjacking victim
especially when as their lawyer reminds
the judge the actual criminal is still
out there no such thing have you ever
heard of a guilty bystander still you
can't say that Jerry George Elaine and
Kramer didn't have it coming in some way
so they just stood there and did nothing
yeah nothing nothing
the actual crime they get arrested for
might be criminal indifference but the
real reason that they get arrested is
that they've amassed so much negative
karma over the years that something
needed a break even their acts of
kindness are tainted with selfishness
like when George tries to take back a
tip when the cashier doesn't notice him
originally tipping character witnesses
during their trial a series of character
witnesses become a greatest hits parade
of some of the funniest Seinfeld
episodes while also reminding viewers
just how many awful things the cast is
done but the idiot clowns did not know
how to order I banned that one they
woman for a year then one day she came
back instead of taking the opportunity
to realize how many people they've hurt
Jerry Elaine George and Kramer seem
largely unmoved and then they're judged
we find the defendants guilty and
sentenced to a year in prison nothing
ever ends oh yeah the second button is
the key button it literally makes the
brakes the shirt look at it it's too
high it's a no-man's land after they get
convicted
Jerry talks to George about his shirt
button placement in an exact rehash of
the very first lines of Seinfeld the
second button literally makes or breaks
the shirt look at it it's too high so no
Mansley george responds by asking if the
had the conversation before and having
completely ignored any chance to redeem
themselves the show ends exactly where
it begins with George and sherry having
a conversation about nothing
controversial conclusion love it or hate
it the ending is certainly bold
unfortunately it was also pretty
divisive Entertainment Weekly gave it a
c-minus at the time while the USA Today
published a scathing review of the
finale on the other hand Grantland
published a defense of the finale in
2015 it wasn't just critics who were
torn either
the actors were divided about the unique
ending Jerry Seinfeld himself initially
defended the show in a reddit AMA saying
I was happy with the Seinfeld finale
because we didn't want to do another
episode as much as we wanted to have
everybody come back to the show we had
so much fun with Julia louis-dreyfus who
played Elaine even made a joke about the
finale on The Late Show with David
Letterman thanks for letting me take
part in another hugely disappointing
series finale not the real ending while
the actual finale of Seinfeld might
still be debated it's not necessarily
the final word from co-creator Larry
David on Curb Your Enthusiasm David put
together a Seinfeld finale more in
keeping with fans expectations when he
brings the cast back together in a ploy
to regain the affections of his ex-wife
in the reunion Jerry has gotten together
with Elaine while George tries to get
back together with his ex wife Amanda
after losing all of his money in a
pyramid scheme
Jerry and Elaine have even had a
daughter together the ending is much
closer to what fans likely pictured when
Seinfeld was wrapping up its run and
David even called the faux reunion quote
a perfect way to do something like that
but not to do it